So Andy, when you were looking at the
source code how did, how'd you get started?
>> I probably didn't do the right way,
whatever that is. I just Googled 2048 source code.
>> Okay.
>> Found myself on GitHub. I felt very confused, but I clicked around
a bit, found some code, copied and pasted, made some changes and then-
>> Right.
>> Ta-da.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Is there a better way I'm guessing?
>> yeah. But we'll talk about that a little
bit more detail later but for now let's just get
a quick look at the code.
>> Okay.
>> Right here in the browser. So since we're in
Chrome, we can just right click, and go to Inspect Element.
>> Okay.
>> And that brings up the development tools.
>> Oh, okay. This is all the code that
I had played with in the wrong way. That's cool.
>> Yeah. So this is the, this is the HTML
here. So that gives the basic structure for the page.
>> Okay.
>> And then over here, we've got the CSS, which
gives the page it's styling, the sort of look and feel.
>>
Okay. Cool. So, the HTML from when I was going over this. This
has things like, we have Head, which is the Header and the Body,
which is basically the whole document. And then you keep going, and we
have, oh that's the Heading. We have Above Game, Game Container and so on.
>> If you just hover over these things, it will
show you what part of the page that elements refers to.
>> And can I modify this right in the browser?
>> Yeah.
>> So if I were to delete?
>> Yikes, okay, I'm going to refresh cause I don't want to break anything
>> Sounds good.
>> Okay so what about what's going on over here?
>> So this is basically telling us you know, what, what color
things should be. What the, the exact positioning of things should be.
>> huh.
>> So for example, it gives the color for
the background, of the main background of the page here.
>> And what does this mean? I, I see HTML, and I see Body over here. I
see HTML. I see Body here.
>> Yeah. So, this is basically saying this rule
applies to HTML elements that basically are called those
things. So anything that starts with HTML or body,
are going to have those rules apprised to them.
>> Okay, and so if I click on this background thing, and I change it
to. Oh that is so cool. Okay. Nice.
So imagine I am trying to figure out what's going on here.
>> Mm hm.
>> How should I spend the next five minutes of my time?
>> Just, you know, pull up the page, right
click Inspect Element, sort of look around the page.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Figure out, you know, maybe like delete some
things to see what corresponds to what on the page.
>> Okay. Well, I'll give it a shot.
>> Alright.
>> Cool. [SOUND]